he is uh the co-host of the show that we
take you to every single day here on nbc
sports on peacock and it's a big weekend
for them as well
michael holly and michael smith's
brother from another will be on right
after this
steelers browns game how are you michael
holly what's going on
man i'm doing well i'm doing very well
as a matter of fact
i'm hearing i i hope i'm not uh speaking
out of school here at all i'm hearing
though it might be a big weekend for you
too
because uh that's what they were telling
us hey eisen
isaac can join you guys yes sir uh
michael uh
even though i've got a four-hour
pre-game show on saturday
at the uh and a four-hour pre-game show
and a four-hour pregame show on sunday
that begins at what we affectionately
refer
to as the ass crack of dawn um
technical term thank you there still is
an i and rich
and eisen i'm a team player i will be
phoning into your uh your show
on sunday night i'll do it that was a
that was a very
eloquent acceptance i really appreciate
that that's good
and i'm gonna ask i heard you talking
earlier i'm gonna ask brandon marshall
today
yes if indeed uh your fastest time was
with him
and what he did i need to know not only
your pastor's time but what he did
to bring that out of you you know the
best coaches they make you reach down
inside yourself
yes you bring out something you didn't
even know you had right but
the best coaches also can teach you in a
way to make make
things relatable and brandon did that
for me
uh we we did uh we had about a couple
hours together
one afternoon um on the campus of
pepperdine
in beautiful malibu california blue baby
um
and um he told me something that
resonated with me
which is to you know because i would
clench my hands i would clench my hands
in a way or
hold them out and sometimes i would hold
them out
uh with palms extended while i'm running
and he was trying to get me to relax and
he said that i should
hold my finger my forefinger and thumb
together
like i was holding a potato chip in each
hand and bring it to my mouth as if i'm
eating chips
that was very relatable to me and and it
was very helpful
but for brandon marshall i remember that
yep
that's a good coaching tip and and all
in all seriousness he's got a great um
he's got a great uh podcast i was
checking it out as part of the
you know the show prep as we go in the
business show prep
diligence uh doing everything but it's
called uh i am athlete
he does a really nice job he's great
brandon marshall and
um fred taylor reggie wayne
who you know uh very well yes and also
uh channing crowder so it's a good group
there
so yeah are you interviewing reggie
wayne at all or you haven't uh that's
that's not part of the broadcast just
brandon so you're talking to
no it's just brandon uh he'll probably
tell some good reggie wayne stories
too bad uh rich i i thought i was going
to have a
a opportunity to pick uh reggie's
reggie's brain
because i always want to talk to people
you talk about wild card weekend yes
and uh the bucks and and washington
football team are playing this weekend
so i always like to talk to people who
played with both
uh brady and manning yep so when he got
to new england i said oh this would be
great you know
guy played with manning for 11 years
let's see what this is like but he was
uh he was with the patriots for a couple
of weeks and then he decided
that was it that was a retirement that
would be a wrap so michael uh you being
somebody who's obviously been around the
patriots organization and brady
and now we have gotten the uh answer to
how
uh either would fare after a 20-year
marriage in brady and belichick how do
you think that brady
uh playoff game is sitting with the
kraft family and
belichick in private moments how do you
think
this is going down michael i think the
craft family is fine with it
i think belichick is is probably mildly
annoyed
uh that tom brady not that he's in the
playoffs because that's not a surprise
right
uh it's that 40 touchdown passes
uh at 43 years old and and grok
coming back because that's the other
part of it it's not just brady it's
brady the grunk
because gronk left and it was clear it
was speculation that gronk left you know
he wasn't having enough fun
and people wondered if belichick has
something to do with it i think it's
clear yeah belichick did have something
to do with it
so when brady got to tampa and then
gronk is back and he looks the same
and he didn't quite look like that for
for most of the 2018 season he did in
the playoffs but in regular season he
was kind of dragging
um so i i think that probably uh gets to
him a little bit
and people always ask me rich i don't
know how you feel about it but people
always ask me like who's more important
brady or belichick
oh now okay well listen i'll i'll i'll
be i'll be transparent yes i have a book
called
belitech and brady yes i do that's the
book title yes
i love it yes but where all books are
sold
i i really do i really do think that's
the right answer it's both of them
and that's not the most exciting answer
for for uh hot
hot take tv and hot take radio but you
know
belichick wouldn't be who he is without
brady brady wouldn't be who he is
without belichick they both would have
super bowls neither of them would have
nine appearances six titles
but uh i think they got to the point
where they just needed to
need to be away from each other um and
that makes sense i mean 20 years
you you hear about how uh a long-lasting
nfl marriage for the lack of better
phrases four
five sometimes eight years maybe i mean
20 is insane and then
the numbers you just threw out it's it
is
and you did it casually because the
reason why you did that is because we
all
know them already but it's insane it's
insane that nine out of 20 times that
they were together uh in the same
organization they made the super bowl
literally almost half of their
one out of every two seasons wound up
with them there that is
insane and so clearly if
the quarterback leaves and the rest of
the roster
isn't ready to uh receive
somebody and the person who does come in
to replace him is so
completely different from the guy who
left and cam
obviously that's not going to wind up uh
with the same
amount of wins as the quarterback going
to a spot with a
maybe his most talented roster and this
is this has got to be part of
you know for somebody in brady who
anything fuels him this has still got to
fuel him right
week in week out tonight on saturday
night on nbc and and every single minute
he takes a snap right now
this will fuel oh yeah i think i think a
lot of things are driving them right now
um like it didn't and when they when
they both go to the hall of fame one day
it will be all love and they'll tell
stories and they'll hug and
and smile but uh toward the end i mean
they were everybody
i think both of them were were taking
things personally that weren't
necessarily personal
um and and one of them it started with
brady with when jimmy garoppolo was
drafted
he was drafted in the second round
and brady he's looking around saying
well wait a minute we we
uh last year we didn't have enough
weapons and you're spending a second
round pick
on the on this quarterback but it drove
him
to after the after garoppolo was drafted
and
belichick mentioned his age on that
draft night too
yeah you know times 37 we know his
contract status so he was 37
when that happened uh and since that
moment
uh he's won three more super bowls since
jimmy garoppolo was drafted
so i think that pushed him to be better
but it also uh ticked him off a bit
and then belichick was was upset that
brady decided that he wasn't going to go
to uh go to ota he was going to do it on
his own now keep in mind rich
we're talking about a grown man here so
tom brady at 24 is trying to
win this parking spot and hey you know
i'm going to set the tone i'm going to
be the first one here at
voluntary workouts and i think we all
get so used to it as football fans
that we think voluntary workouts we
think you have to be there
and we kind of look down i think we kind
of kind of judgey
on players who don't go there but i
think i think if you're tom brady and at
the age of 40
after being at otas for 16 straight
years you decide
okay i'm going to spend more time with
my family
i i think he gets the benefit of that
doubt but belichick didn't give it to
him what's funny michael yeah
they had they had a lot of squabbles a
lot of petty stuff well and again that's
all in the past um
and now brady's in his current spot with
a with an opportunity to
really make it uh a cinderella type
story for somebody who's
been the belle of the ball for 20 years
you know which is kind of crazy
and um it's funny we had bruce arians uh
on the show about a month ago right
chris is that when we had
bruce on about a month ago and i i asked
him about coaching brady
and and the one item that got picked up
in the new england media
uh because we we saw it and plus my
brother-in-law scott shuster who you
know very well
uh he'll let me know on occasion when
something gets picked up
uh what got picked up michael was
aryan's talking about how brady works so
well with the young players
and takes the time to coach him up and a
lot of new englanders were like
what you know they're like what
was that like he's gonna actually take
people aside and
and uh and and and i'm wondering what
where that
comment lands with you on that
see i i'm not surprised by that the
reason
it got picked up in new england because
so much attention was given to
you know brady being frustrated with
young receivers
and and uh kind of being demonstrative
on the field but let me ask you this
rich
um if somebody i i'm not saying i'm just
gonna use an example let's say tj
jefferson
i mean i just you know just this the
first thing that came to my mind
just say tj jefferson is not doing the
job the right right way for the rich
eisenhower
yes does rich eisen coddle does he say
listen tj you're very talented young man
i'm so grateful to have you
or if it happens in real time
supposed to uh do something at the
precise time
and tj drops the ball not that he would
ever do that you might
kind of go off on him okay so now first
of all i greatly appreciate the analogy
not from tj's point of view this is
about me that i am
the michigan man like brady in this
instance who's the quarterback of this
roster
but tj i will give you the floor for you
to answer
that question oh you've not that it's
happened a lot but there have been one
once or twice for you shot me a look
because i may have said something or
done something it doesn't happen a lot
but you've given me a look once or twice
chris have i given him looks do i give
him looks
uh oh my god come on now it doesn't
happen a lot
i think i'm no i can't i'm the company
i'm the company who came in and exposed
well no i i get your point no maker i
get your point you know brady doesn't
suffer fools on occasion but i think the
way that the bucks were saying is that
and is that he needed to um show
i guess the brady slash patriot way to
some people
and uh that's another way in tampa
um but it's all come out in the wash
with him being a uh
a wild card quarterback and it's such a
fascinating conversation that has
gone so deep that with only two minutes
to go it's
far less amount of time than i wanted to
spend on the fact that you and
michael smith in the rich eisen show
fantasy league
uh for basketball are dfl right now i
mean you're so far
back it's it's we need a telescope to
see where you guys are like what gives
hot garbage right now what is happening
well okay well
i'm gonna tell you what happened all
right because i'm a i am a good
co general manager okay so i would never
i would never
sell out uh somebody on my staff i would
never do that
but michael smith
uh he is he has floated on the air
several times he said you know i would
leave the show in a second if i could be
the assistant to the assistant general
manager he said that many times
on brother from another our show uh that
we do together he said
you know hey if louis riddick gets a job
and he wants to call me
uh yeah i'll take it or anybody else boy
that's right so
on draft night on fantasy draft night i
said okay i'm going to show you that you
really don't know what you're talking
about
i'm going to let you draft our fantasy
basketball
oh wow i'm gonna let you drive and
and this is not even these are no you're
not you don't have to make projections
like general managers do
these are known commodities all you have
to do is
no take the guy that you know can play
and pick them
and assemble a roster and i'll just tell
you that the guy until he came back
happy that he passed on lebron james
twice
okay
well michael we we've got 30 seconds
till we have to throw to break here on
peacock so please tell
uh michael smith that he's not off to a
great start
for general manager of the year in the
rich eisen show big ballers
fantasy basketball league and that his
grocery
shopping items that he has purchased are
already past expiration
um and i will see you and michael uh on
sunday night we'll chat look forward
look forward to it rich can't wait to
hang out with you on a sunday night you
got it take care tj all right brother
michael holly everybody get that draft
board ready for the cowboys there you go
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here